WOMEN AND YOUNG PEOPLE,
HOLLYWOOD, TIME'S UP.
THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION IN
NEW YORK IS MONICA CROWLEY, FROM
THE LONDON CENTER FROM POLICY
RESEARCH AND JULIE, THE DIGITAL
DIRECTOR OF LIFESTYLE TITLES AT
"TIMES" INC. I SAID A LOT.
TELL ME WHAT I GOT WRONG.
CORRECT ME.
TUTOR ME.
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
ADDRESSES TO CAMPAIGN FOR 2018.
THESE WOMEN ARE STANDING UP FOR
WOMEN WHO ARE UNABLE TO SPEAK UP
FOR THEMSELVES.
LOW PAYING JOBS WORKING IN
FARMS, HOSPITALS, HOTELS AND
RESTAURANTS.
WOMEN WHO DON'T HAVE THE
PLATFORM TO TALK ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BUT EXPERIENCE LARGE
AMOUNTS OF SELECTS.
-- SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THEY ARE CONNECTING THESE WOMEN
WITH LEGAL EXPERTS AND MONEY.
THEY ARE LOBBYING ORGANIZATIONS
FOR LEGISLATION THAT HELP PEOPLE
FOR LEGISLATION THAT HELP PEOP E
PEOPLE.
I AM CONFUSED WHY YOU SEEM TO
THINK THIS IS A NEFARIOUS
PROCESS.
OCTOBER.
ONE OF THE CORE MISSION
STATEMENTS OF THIS GROUP IS
FOCUSSED ON DONALD TRUMP.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT LENDS SOME
POLITICAL TAINT TO THE OTHERWISE
LAUDABLE GOAL OF PROTECTING
WOMEN IN THE WORK FORCE?
THIS FROM AN INDUSTRY THAT MADE
MILLION DOLLARS HYPERSEXULEIZING
WOMEN?
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF YOUNG WOMEN
WHO ARE NAIVE AND IGNORANT OF
THE WAY MEN ARE IN THE
WORKPLACE.
NOW THEY GET MILLION DOLLARS FOR
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
POPULATED BY ALL LIBERAL
ACTRESSES.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THEY
JUST FOUND THEIR MORAL
CONSCIENCE?
THAT'S NOT BIZARRE.
THEY FOCUSSED ON TRUMP RIGHT
FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> THE THINGS YOU POINT OUT
ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY,
HYPERSEXUALIZING WOMEN AND
TREATING THEM POORLY, I THINK
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT PART OF THIS
MISSION IS TRYING TO ADDRESS.
80% OF BOARD MEMBERS IN
HOLLYWOOD ARE MEN.
96% OF DIRECTORS ARE MEN.
THESE STORIES ARE TOLD BY MEN.
>> Laura: THESE STORIES ARE NOT
JUST TOLD BY MEN.
WOMEN WRITE THEIR OWN STORIES
ABOUT --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> 96% OF THE DIRECTORS ARE MEN.
>> Laura: MONICA, THEY HAVE A
GROUP CALLED 50-50 FOR GENDER
PARITY FOR 2020 AN ELECTION
YEAR, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> YES, THIS LOOKS LIKE THE LATE
MOBILIZATION OF NEVER LET A GOOD
CRISIS GO TO WASTE.
WOMEN DO SUFFER AT THE HAND OF
BUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS AND WITH
THESE LATEST GROUPS IS AN EFFORT
BY THE LEFT TO TAKE THIS GENUINE
CRISIS AND HIJACK INTO 2
DIRECTIONS.
ONE THE LIBERAL LEFT
WINGDIRECTION AND HAVE WOMEN
THAT SUPPLANT MAN IN POSITIONS
OF POWER AND AUTHORITY.
IF WOMEN DESERVE THOSE
POSITIONS, MORE POWER TO THEM.
IF THEY DON'T, THEN WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
DIRECTION OF DONALD TRUMP.
IN MANY WAYS THE ACCUSERS OF
DONALD TRUMP IN LATE OCTOBER
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION, THAT
WAS AHEAD OF ITS TIME.
RIGHT BEFORE THE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN STORY BROKE THIS WIDE
THEY WILL TRY TO REANIMATE THIS
WHOLE THING TO TARGET DONALD
>> YOU GUYS ARE THE ONLY ONES --
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO GET INTO
ANOTHER ISSUE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU HOW THIS CAN
DEDICATEED TO DERAILING THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY, THIS HAPPENED
BEFORE THE ELECTION ON.
NEW YEAR'S EVE THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTED THAT HILLARY
CLINTON BACKERS GAVE $700,000 TO
ANY WOMAN WHO CAME FORWARD WITH
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
NOT ONE WOMAN CAME FORWARD.
IS THERE ANY TAINT WITH THAT
MONEY FROM HILLARY'S GOOD
COMING FROM.
I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
EXPLOITING OR DIGGING UP THAT
SORT OF DIRT.
IT WASN'T LIKE THIS MONEY WOULD
THIS WAS MONEY TO GO TOWARD
LEGAL FEES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
EXPLOITING PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY HARASSED.
THERE EVIDENCE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN LOTS OF ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
HE SPOKE ABOUT TOUCHING WOMEN IN
A SEXUAL MANNER WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT.
THERE IS SMOKE THERE.
THERE ARE WOMEN OUT THERE WHO
HAVE BEEN MISTREATED BY DONALD
TRUMP AND OUR COUNTRY DESERVES
TO KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: DAVID BROCK IS A LONG
TIME PAL OF HILLARY.
RUNS ALL OF THESE GROUPS THAT
SUPPORT HILLARY.
NOW IT'S IRONIC SHE IS BROUGHT
IN BY HOLLYWOOD TO OVERSEE THIS
EFFORT TO EXPUNGE ALL SEXUAL
BIAS FROM HOLLYWOOD.
MONICA, I AGREE WHAT YOU SAY.
MEN IN POSITION OF POWER TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF YOUNG WOMEN WHO
NEED AN OPPORTUNITY.
THERE IS ALSO A POLITICAL
ELEMENT RUNNING RIGHT THROUGH.
THIS AS MOST OF THE PEOPLE, MOST
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
ALL OF THESE HOLLYWOOD PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN ACCUSED, IS THERE
ONE CONSERVATIVE.
MOST.
OF THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DEMOCRATS.
>> THE STORY ON BROCK AND THE
MON
MO
MONY THAT WENT INTO LISA BLOOM'S
FIRM, WE ARE SEEING A
WEAPONIATION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THIS IS A TRAGEDY
BECAUSE THEY ARE REALLY CASES.
THE WOMEN VICTIMIZED BY THIS BAD
BEHAVIOR WILL HAVE THEIR